بما اننا نشهد موسم كاس العالم هذه الايام
نشاهد مباريات كره القدم كل يوم بات الحظر
واجب دراسه المانيه حديثه كشفت ان مشاهده
مباريات كره القدم تمتلك تاثيرا سلبيا على
القلب ونصحت بالتخفيف من الحماس المبالغه
فيها
مشاهده الاحداث الرياضيه قد تؤثر على
القلب والاوعيه عن طريق رفع مستويات
التوتر العاطفي الاضافه الى زياده ضغط
الدم ومعدل ضربات القلب بشكل ملحوظ
الباحثون لاحظوا ان المشاركين في الدراسه
عنه من ارتفاع ضغط الدم وصلوا الى معدلات
مرتفعه من ضربات القلب والى مستويات خطيره
ايضا خلال المباريات الحاسمه كما بقيت
القراءات عاليه لعده ساعات بعد المباراه
كما تبين ان الاثاره الناتجه عن اللعبه
تؤدي الى زياده مستويات هرمون الاجهاد هذه
النتائج السابقه التي ابهرت ان الضغط
الناجم عن مشاهده وتشجيع كره القدم اثناء
المنافسات الكبيره يمكن ان يكون له اثار
قاسيه
يبدو ان كره القدم تقسم الزملاء في مكتب
العربيه بالاردن خلينا نتعرف على
المنتخبات التي يدعمونها في المونديال وعن
توقعاتهم وايضا
لم اشهد يوما خلافا بين موظفي مكتب
العربيه حتى بدات مباريات كاس العالم
وانقسم العرب وعربيين كل منهم يشجعوا
فريقا لكنني اتمنى ان تسود الروح الرياضيه
اجواء مكتبنا من جديد
يا شباب
شو رايك
البرتغال ليه زوجي بشجل البرتغال بس
والعنصر النسائي
من لما كان يلعب فيها زيد الدين زيدان
وانا بحب هذا الفريق وانا معكي فرنسي
ان شاء الله ممتاز ممتاز يعني الكم
النهائيه فرنسا
فرنسا
[موسيقى]
دكتور اسامه النعيمي دكتور يسعد صباحك
دائما معنا التعصب الكروي الحماس الزائد
يقول الى مشاكل صحيه ونفسيه خطيره قد تكون
ما رايكم بذلك دكتور
صباح الخير نادين
متصفحين صباح الخير عادل صباح الخير عبد
المجيد صباح الخير على اذاعه البرنامج من
الاردن بس ما ادري ليش فرنسا كانهم الشباب
صار لهم اسبوع نايمين لكن كلامك صحيح هذه
الدراسه ليست جديده طبعا كانت دراسه سابقه
اشارت لهذا الشيء وكانت اصلا على الجمهور
الامريكي في لعبه كره القدم الامريكيه
واكتشفه انه كميه الضغط والتوتر اللي تحدث
قبل المباريات واثناء المباريات وبعد
المباريات بسبب ارتفاع شديد في التوتر
العام وضغط في همم الجسم نتيجه افراز نوع
من الهرمونات الادرينالين اللي يؤثر على
عضله القلب وعلى كل الجهاز العصبي لكن
الاكثر خطوره بنظري انا هو همم هرمون
الكورتيزون اللي كل انواع الخلايا في
الجسم وهو هرمون المسؤول عن البقاء
واستمرار الخليلي لذلك الدراسات اثبت انه
الناس المتعصبين بكل اشياء اعمارهم قصيره
جدا
الذي يعاني من التعصب الك
روي شديد
الغالي لا يمكن المقارنه بين الامرين
بعض المراكز البحثيه اعاده التعصب الرياضي
الى التعلق المرضي وقالت انه بعض الاشخاص
يبحثوا عن اي انتصارات حتى يثبته انهم
افضل من الاخرين بل ان بعضهم اعادها الى
العنف الدفين داخل الانسان اللي كذبته
الاديان والمجتمعات والقوانين لكن كان هذا
المتنفس الوحيد امامهم ان يعلن تفوقهم على
الاخرين هل الانسان المتعصب رياضيا
المتعصب في اشياء اخر همم من خبرتي
الشخصيه مع بعض الاشخاص اللي يكرهوني
بصداقتهم اكتشفت انه الناس المتعلقين جدا
باشياء رياضيه معظم الاحيان من الصعب
النقاش معهم في اشياء اخرى طيب دكتور من
تونس ان السؤال نفسه لاي ماده يمكن ان
تغضب بسبب مباراه كره القدم او ترشش حسب
التونسيه
[تصفيق]
نقعد نقعد نهاري
نقول لك
بلاستيك
[ضحك]
ادفع
الكره
فلا تكتك في التشكيله والدنيا كلها
وهو ما يسمعك فيا بيقول كانك حاضرك
معك
طيب
ونفسيه ايضا هل تنصح بان الواحد يفرغ عن
هذا التعصب يكسر ويعمل مثل العادل
انا اعجبني اضراب الجوع وراح اجرب المره
الجايه لاسوي فيها دايد لكن طبعا انا ضد
فكره انه الواحد يعبر عن العنف بعنف من
حقك انه انت تكون متعلق بفريق من حقك انه
تعلق بفكره وتفتن بها من حقك ان تعبر عن
شعور تظن انه هو شعور وطني بحيث انه تشجع
فريقك لكن اذا نفسه ايذاء الاخرين هذا ما
له علاقه بالرياضه خلي بالك من الرياضه
واحده من الفنون الراقيه فكيف يكون
التعبير عن حبنا لفريقنا وحبنا لبلدنا هو
باذاء انفسنا وذاء الاخرين طبعا انا لا
استطيع
كله ضد الدكتور ما ادري يمكن لان هو
يعرفني على حقيقتي
ههه والله يا دكتور
اذا انكسر الموبايل دكتور انا بس احب
انا بس انا بس احب اقول انه مباريات كاس
العالم السابقه لاربعه اثبتت انه الفريق
اللي يلعب بعقلانيه يفوز والفريق اللي
يلعب بعاطفه يخسر بل يخسر بشده واثبت انه
الاعداد النفسي لا يقل اهميه عن الاعداد
البدني اللي ما لاحظ هذه الاشياء معناها
لن يتطور كمنتخب تعبيرنا احنا عن حبنا
لهذا المنتخب او ذاك هذا حق اصيل لنا بل
بعض الاحيان يصل الى مرحله الوطنيه لكن
اليوم مش لمرحله اذا الاخرين
هي مباركه
في حال خسرت السعوديه اما بالارجنتين
اقل من خمس ساعات طبعا ههه
ما راح اقول لك ما راح اقول لك درجه النكد
اللي راح اكون فيها لكن خليني اقول لك انا
مباشره بعد المباراه عندي عياده فيجب ان
اتحمل الامر واستقبل الناس اللي جايه تصرخ
بوجهي
امين يارب العالمين
يا رب العالمين
طبعا المباراه بتشد الاعصاب قوي يعني
درجه التعصب بتكون عاليه جدا يعني ممكن
تتعامل بكل حواسك
بنظراتك
بحركات في اليد بكده يعني
من زمان
مثلا القهوه
[موسيقى]